das hier ist kein Fried Chicken aber es
kommt gefährlich nah dran wir brauchen
austandpilze dazu ein bisschen
Buttermilch einfach bisschen nach
Augenmaß Knoblauchpulver rein
räucherpaprika cayenpfeffer für die
Schärfe und weißen Pfeffer für diesen
KFC Touch und verquürlen wenn alles
schön verquürt ist über unsere
austandpilze drüber geben und so lassen
wir sie jetzt ein bisschen marinieren
macht euch dann eine paniermischung
einfach mit den Gewürzen auf die ihr
Lust habt ich ja wieder weißen Pfeffer
drin paar Kräuter also dann machen wir
uns ans panieren wir nehmen uns einen
Pilz aus der Marinade und der hat so
schon fast die Form von dem Wing ihr
werdet gleich sehen wenn das Ding
paniert ist ganz anderer Schnack können
ein paar Tropfen so hier hineingeen dann
haben wir diese kleinen Flakes und dann
rein da von allen Seiten und das
wiederholen wir jetzt mit all unseren
austerpilzen dann fangen wir mal an
unsere auspilze zu frittieren direkt
rein ins Öl ich glaube das wird sehr
sehr krass guckt euch bitte diese Farbe
einmal an man würde wirklich denken dass
das einfach chickenwingngs sind heftig
geil jetzt nur noch anrichten und fertig
sind unsere Fried eyster mushrooms